salut je lance une chaîne alors il faut
bien que je la présente je m'appelle
paul et je suis prof de philosophie
pourquoi le patient zéro je pourrais
dire parce que j'aime bien le nombre 0
et parce que j'aime bien la lettre z
je pourrais dire parce que j'aime bien
l'idée que 0 c'est le début et z c'est
la fin je pourrais dire parce que j'aime
bien les expériences de pensée
utilitariste où on sacrifie de patients
0 souvent au début et parfois la faim
aussi
nietzsche à cette expression il qualifie
le philosophe de médecins de la
civilisation
parce que ce dernier aurait la capacité
de diagnostiquer les maladies culturel
de son temps et moi j'aime bien l'idée
que s'il est capable de les
diagnostiquer c'est d'abord parce qu'il
est le premier malade de la civilisation
c'est en lui même qui les identifient il
a donc choper les versions plus ou moins
bénigne des maladies que son époque a
produites les anxiétés les phobies les
passions tristes le biais cognitifs et
c'est en gros c'est un mec qui va mal et
qui cherche à aller mieux
alors x ausculte ils découvrent des
pathologies et s'ils y arrivent trouver
des remèdes invente des soins de sorte
que pour être un bon médecin
il faut déjà être un bon malade être
sacrément malade il faut savoir
reconnaître les problèmes pour trouver
des solutions
moi je me dis si je suis malade à cause
de la civilisation c'est à dire à cause
des pathologies générés par ma culture
et je ne vois pas d'ailleurs pourquoi j
échapperait alors il ya de bonnes
chances que d'autres aient les mêmes
problèmes que moi donc si je trouve un
remède qui marche pour moi il ya des
chances qu'il marche pour d'autres je
considère qu'il ya plein de vidéos super
sur youtube qui apprennent des trucs
passionnants
monsieur fille ou mon fabulous sound for
all hygiène mentale par des billets ce
différend elles aident à mieux penser je
voudrais participer moi aussi à cet
ensemble en proposant un angle
supplémentaires pour mettre en lumière
certaines expériences liées à nos
pathologies
je serai d'autant plus prudents que je
vais oser être prescriptif oui je dis
prescriptive comme dans prescription
parce que le patient zéro c'est bien
implicitement ici aussi un médecin mais
je ne suis pas dogmatique non plus je
vais simplement proposer des diagnostics
je pars du principe que percevoir la
maladie c'est la première étape de la
guérison
c'est donc bien une question de santé en
quelque sorte
l'idée c'est de donner des pistes pour
apprendre à ce diagnostic et mais il ya
un enjeu supplémentaire je reconnais et
il est politique plutôt qu'individuelle
je dirais donc qu'il concerne la santé
du collectif je pars du principe que
quand on est trop malade on devient par
la force des choses très préoccupé par
soi même on essaie d'aller mieux tout
simplement
mais si on n'y arrive pas alors ça nous
prend toute notre énergie on se démène
on s'essouffle
on dépense tout son temps pour soi vous
me voyez venir sans doute le but c'est
aussi d'aller mieux pour s'occuper un
peu moins de soi et faire plus de place
pour l'autre comme un système de vases
communicants se libérer de ses
une pathologie ce serait aussi un moyen
de devenir un meilleur amis voisins
collègues citoyens l'hypothèse sous
jacente c'est que mieux on va plus on
est disposé à se préoccuper de ceux qui
vont moins bien
j'espère donc c'est un petit peu
l'objectif rêvé de cette chaîne youtube
que ces vidéos vous aideront à aller
mieux et indirectement aideront aussi
ceux autour de vous à bientôt